[Musique]
caméra prête attention lumière ça tourne
envoyez la musique et actions puis les
gens d'ailleurs start i would be used as
morel et au littoral qui rigole
angleterre aujourd'hui pour une tournée
nationale
nous faisons ça on attend dans le
financement de notre prochain film je
vais m'assurer que cette tournée
commence du bon pied
regarde la tour eiffel c'est incroyable
d'avoir toujours autant de succès en
utilisant toujours les meubles vieux gag
mais voilà quelle merveilleuse réception
et spies pas mal de duos comiques pour
le prix d'un c'était presque vides hier
soir j'ai l'impression que les gens ne
veulent plus voir laurel et hardy
elle ne te demande pas un peu trop bébé
tu connais stable
[Musique]
tu es aurait pu te séparer de oliver il
y à bien longtemps les choses aller à
merveille seulement tu m'en a voulu
parce que j'ai fait un film avec un
autre que toi j'en ai pas dormi pendant
des jours quand on me l'a dit tu n'es
qu'un sale feignant tu as eu de la
chance de me rencontrer de la chance à
ces ma vie auprès d'un type qui se cache
derrière sa machine à écrire tu m'as
trahi
tu as trahi notre amitié tu n'as rien
vous ne pouvez pas retourner sur scène
dans votre état je tenais mais je ne
laisserai pas ses tournées de foot
envoyée au cimetière
on n'aurait jamais dû faire cette
tournée je laime ida je n'abandonne pas
un stan le spectacle doit continuer
quand on regarde nos films il n'ya que
l'oubli
[Musique]
on est tous là pour l'autre par marie
je ne regrette rien du toit non plus tu
ne dois rien regretter
oui
dams et monsieur monsieur stan laurel et
monsieur oliver hardy
[Applaudissements]
ça va me manquer notre duo toi aussi tu
vas mourir